y
un nuevo intento por frenar las
protestas favoreciendo la baja del
combustible el presidente guillermo
lasso espera abordar una de las
principales demandas de los indígenas he
decidido reducir el precio de la
gasolina extra y echo país en 10
centavos por galón y el diésel también
en 10 centavos por galón
la medida se da luego que el lazo
levantar el estado de emergencia que
había impuesto en seis provincias y de
iniciar un diálogo con los líderes de
las protestas en ese país la producción
petrolera se encuentra en niveles
críticos y ha disminuido el 50 por
ciento de su producción dejando de
percibir alrededor de 120 millones de
dólares según el ministerio de energía
los precios de los combustibles ya
estaban congelados desde el año pasado
todos consideran que el precio de los
combustibles se ha convertido en la
piedra angular que mantiene el conflicto
y aunque como gobierno tenemos muy claro
que este factor no es el que origina los
problemas de los ecuatorianos debemos
pensar en el bien común y la paz
ciudadana los indígenas también piden el
control de los precios de los productos
agrícolas y un mayor presupuesto para la
educación para ellos el reciente anuncio
no es suficiente
hemos de luchar también otra hasta
conseguir nuestros derechos si estás
para por lo menos
basta mirar la pública que tenemos
el cierre de las vías y la escasez han
provocado también algunas
manifestaciones contra los bloqueos que
iniciaron el pasado 13 de junio
entretanto los legisladores discuten una
solicitud de la oposición para destituir
al presidente lazo aunque se requiere el
voto de al menos 92 de los 137
legisladores una cifra difícil de
alcanzar tomando en cuenta que la
oposición cuenta con apenas 50 curules